the Grammy nominations came out this
week among the people nominated for best
audio book was senator Bernie Sanders
that's right here's the word thing most
people assumed it was a political book
it turns out it's a romance novel and
Bernie reads it himself I couldn't
believe it but take a listen the
revolution of Kassandra by senator
bernie sanders there in the candle light
stood the most beautiful man Cassandra
had ever seen excuse me miss I'm Derek
the new Huntsman of castle Burlington
you must be Lord Burlington's daughter
Cassandra Cassandra felt a longing in
her womanliness that could not be denied
yes I'm Cassandra she had the urge to
run to him and to kiss him but she
cannot for they were both prisoners of a
patriarchal economic caste system in
which the wealthy use their political
and financial leverage to create a
perpetual underclass and to ensure that
Cassandra would never be free to satiate
the desire that burned in her loins free
to indulge her carnal impulses free the
way that College should be for everyone
what's that sir did you say you want to
hear more is how you just said you just
said you want to hear more is that what
you said yeah he wants more this man
wants more I am too please let's listen
to a little more Casandra laid in
Derrick's simple yet sustainable Hut
making love to him of his filthy
sustainable cut this feels so right and
natural much like the notion of
single-payer health care the central
part Derek cried out millionaires the
millionaires billionaires trillionaires
their passions peak together an
exquisite crescendo that it could at the
same time simultaneous they lay there
for a moment until the arousal went down
like the earning power of working-class
families
I don't know if you recognize the voice
anyone recognize the voice Andy Richter
Andy Richter I didn't know you're good
at Bernie Sanders impression I have a
cold so it works better
no hey probably wouldn't work is good
about it now cold Bernie with a call
you